Paul's a cop in New York-- Paul Bacon. Officer Bacon. No jokes, please. And one night he did his regular 4:00 to midnight shift, and then he was told that they needed him to cover a second shift in another part of the city. In a little security booth. In an area they were protecting from terrorists, basically.
保罗是纽约的一名警察——保罗·培根。培根警官。请别开玩笑。一天晚上，他像往常一样值了从凌晨4点到午夜的班，然后被告知需要他在城市的另一个地方再值一班。在一个小的保安亭里。基本上是在一个他们保护免受恐怖分子袭击的区域。
At 2:00 AM the other officer who's working in this booth with him takes a lunch break. Goes and takes a nap. And then at 3:00 AM it's Paul's turn for a break. He's exhausted. Remember, he had already worked a full shift as a patrolman. And he decides that he's also going to take a nap. So he gets into his patrol car. And he drives it out into this parking lot a little ways away from the security booth.
凌晨2点，和他一起在岗亭工作的另一名警察去吃午饭了。去打了个盹。凌晨3点轮到保罗休息了。他精疲力竭。记住，他已经作为巡警值满了一个整班。他决定他也去打个盹。于是他坐进巡逻车，开到了离保安亭不远的一个停车场。
I parked my car in the one available spot thinking, no, this is a parking lot. Nobody's going to be coming by here. It's going to be fine. And so I turned off the ignition and just sat there.
我把车停在唯一一个空位上，心想，不，这是一个停车场。不会有人经过这里的。应该没问题。所以我关掉点火开关，就坐在那儿。
And I realized I can't-- I don't think I'm going to be able to fall asleep sitting up. So I got out of the driver's seat, got in back, and closed the door. And I was asleep within seconds.
我意识到我不能——我觉得我坐着是没法睡着的。所以我离开驾驶座，坐到后座，关上车门。几秒钟内我就睡着了。
I had set my alarm watch to go off so that I would get up in plenty of time to go back on post so my partner wouldn't worry where I was. And everything would be fine. It would be smooth.
我把闹钟手表定好，这样我就有足够的时间回去上岗，免得我的搭档担心我在哪儿。一切都会好起来的。会很顺利的。
But I woke up a few seconds before my alarm with this terrible realization, which is that I was locked in the back. I just-- I was like-- [GASPING] I'm trapped. That was my first thought. Because you don't get out of the back of a police car. The back of the police car is for prisoners.
但我比闹钟提前几秒钟醒来，心中有一种可怕的认识，那就是我被锁在后座了。我只是——我想——[喘气]我被困住了。这是我的第一个念头。因为你不能从警车后座出来。警车的后座是给囚犯坐的。
And you know, I never really thought about it, that a police car is really just like a rolling jail cell.
你知道，我从没想过，警车实际上就像一个流动的监狱牢房。
That's exactly right. And also, it's hermetically sealed. And remember, it was very cold that night. It was February. And I had closed the grating to the front. And the windows were up, so it was really-- you could just feel there was less oxygen in the air. And also, all the windows were all fogged up, so I could barely see out. And I started to panic.
完全正确。而且，它是完全密封的。记住，那天晚上很冷。那是二月。我关上了前排的格栅。车窗关着，所以真的——你能感觉到空气中的氧气变少了。而且，所有的窗户都起雾了，所以我几乎看不见外面。我开始恐慌。
I reached for both of the door handles. Neither of them worked. And so I rolled over on my side, and I pounded against the door as hard as I could with both my feet. And there's just no way out of this car.
我伸手去拉两个车门把手。都没用。所以我侧身翻滚，用双脚尽我所能地猛踢车门。但这辆车根本出不去。
It's dark. It's cold. But he's only 60 feet away from the security booth where his partner is. And he's right next to a sidewalk. All he needs is for somebody to see him, come over, and lift the door handle from the outside.
天黑了。很冷。但他离他搭档所在的保安亭只有60英尺远。他就靠在人行道旁边。他只需要有人看见他，走过来，从外面拉开车门把手。
And he gets lucky. A Pepsi truck parks right on the street right in front of him. He waves frantically at the driver. He pounds on the glass. He can see the driver peering in at him. And then the driver flees. He flees. Who is going to help some maniac trapped in the back of a police car?
他很幸运。一辆百事可乐卡车停在前面的街上。他疯狂地向司机挥手。他猛敲玻璃。他能看见司机正盯着他看。然后司机逃跑了。他跑了。谁会去帮一个被困在警车后座的疯子呢？
My next thought was, well, maybe somebody else will come by. And so I wrote-- in the steam on the window I wrote the word "help." And I did it backwards. But then I got to thinking, well, that's not going to be any more convincing. So I wrote-- underneath help I wrote, "I'm a cop." But unfortunately, nobody came by to read my message.
我下一个念头是，好吧，也许会有别人经过。所以我写——在窗户的蒸汽上我写了“救命”两个字。我写反了。但后来我开始想，好吧，这不会有任何说服力。所以我写——在“救命”下面我写了，“我是警察。”但不幸的是，没有人经过来读我的信息。
His police radio's in the front seat, out of reach. And 3:00 in the morning, exhausted, panicked, it takes him 25 minutes to remember that he is carrying a cell phone-- a cell phone he says he almost never uses. But here's the problem. He's working with an officer that he's never met before in a place he's never been before.
他的警用对讲机在前座，够不到。凌晨3点，精疲力竭，恐慌之中，他花了25分钟才想起自己带着手机——一部他自称几乎从不使用的手机。但问题在于，他和一位从未谋面的警察一起在从未去过的地方工作。
He has no idea what the phone number is to that little booth just 60 feet away from his parked car-- that little booth where right now, his partner is expecting him back on post, wondering where he is. His first great idea of the night was to take a nap. Now he had a second great idea.
他根本不知道离他停车的地方只有60英尺远的小亭子的电话号码——那个小亭子，他搭档现在正期待他回去上岗，纳闷他在哪里。他那天晚上的第一个好主意是去打个盹。现在他有了第二个好主意。
I did what I thought I would never have to do ever in my life. And that is to call 911 as a cop. When the operator came on very shortly, she says, well, don't worry. We'll put this through to your central dispatcher.
我做了我想这辈子永远都不必做的事。那就是以警察的身份拨打911。接线员很快上线，她说，好吧，别担心。我们会把你转接到你的中央调度员那里。
And she was about to get off the phone with me. And I said, well, wait. There's this very, very important thing to tell the dispatcher. And that is that this needs to go over the radio as a non-emergency. Because any time that a cop requests help and it's not qualified in any way, it sends out the cavalry.
她正要挂断我的电话。我说，等等。有一件非常、非常重要的事情要告诉调度员。那就是这需要通过无线电作为非紧急事件发送。因为任何时候警察请求帮助，如果没有任何限定，它就会派出大部队。
Everybody drops everything they're doing and comes very quickly to that location. And that's a dangerous situation, and all because I made this stupid mistake. So I said, please, make sure that you specify it's a non-emergency. I swear, within a minute, lights and sirens coming from all directions.
每个人都会放下手中的工作，非常迅速地赶到那个地点。那是一个危险的情况，而这一切仅仅因为我犯了这个愚蠢的错误。所以我说，请务必说明是非紧急情况。我发誓，不到一分钟，从四面八方传来了警灯和警笛声。
Now, part of the chaos is coming from the fact that Paul wasn't really exactly sure where he was. Remember, this is not his regular precinct, so cops are zooming around, just trying to find him. This seems like way too much commotion even for that. Something has gone very, very wrong. So Paul dials 911 again. They tell him that his call had gone out as a 1013. 1013. Officer down.
现在，混乱的部分原因在于保罗并不确定他到底在哪里。记住，这不是他平时的辖区，所以警察们四处狂奔，只是试图找到他。即使考虑到这一点，这也显得太小题大作了。一定是出了什么非常、非常糟糕的问题。所以保罗再次拨打了911。他们告诉他，他的呼叫被作为1013发出了。1013。警官倒地。
Like, as if a cop was being beaten, or had just been shot. And that's why everybody was going all over the place. My call had basically woken up the entire midnight squad. Probably half that squad was also sleeping, and now I had gotten everybody's blood going.
就像有警察正在被殴打，或者刚刚中枪一样。这就是为什么每个人都到处乱跑。我的呼叫基本上惊醒了整个午夜小队。可能那个小队的一半人也在睡觉，现在我把所有人的血性都调动起来了。
So my partner up in the booth finally got up and started walking down into the parking lot. And I saw him coming. And I took my flashlight off my belt. And I'm shaking my flashlight like crazy, just to show him that this is not a headlight of some car. This is a person being very creative, and very emphatic about letting you know that this is somebody stuck.
所以我在岗亭里的搭档终于起来，开始往停车场走。我看见他来了。我从腰带上取下我的手电筒。我疯狂地摇晃着我的手电筒，只是为了让他看到这不是什么汽车的前灯。这是一个非常具有创造性，并且非常强调让你知道这是有人被困住的人。
And he sees me from about 50 yards away. And he takes his flashlight off and jingles it back at me, and then starts to walk away. He's just thinking I'm having a good time, you know? Like, ha ha ha. He was walking away. So I had to rap really hard on my window again. And I rapped so hard that I cut my knuckles, but he got the point. And he came down to my car, just lifted the door handle. It took him two seconds to let me out.
他在大约50码外看见了我。他取下他的手电筒，对我晃了晃，然后开始走开。他只是以为我在玩得很开心，你知道吗？就像，哈哈。他走开了。所以我不得不再次用力敲击我的窗户。我敲得太用力，把指关节都割破了，但他明白了。他走到我的车前，只是拉开了车门把手。他只用了两秒钟就把我放了出来。
So he's free, and they call off the cavalry. Nobody in his regular precinct ever found out about it.
所以他自由了，他们取消了大部队。他平时所在的辖区里从来没有人发现这件事。
Today on our radio show we bring you stories like this one. Stories that begin with a bright idea-- like, for instance, you're going to park your car 60 feet from your partner, climb in, and take a nap. And then things happen. More than you bargained for, more than you wanted.
今天在我们的电台节目中，我们带给你像这样的故事。这些故事以一个好主意开始——比如，你打算把车停在离搭档60英尺远的地方，钻进去，打个盹。然后事情就发生了。超过了你预想的，超过了你想要的。
From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Each week we bring you a bunch of stories organized around a single thought. And this week, that thought is "It Seemed Like a Good Idea at the Time." Our show in four acts today, each of which starts off with great hope and a shiny new idea.
来自芝加哥WBEZ，这是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。每周我们带给你一系列围绕一个思想组织的各种故事。而这一周，这个思想是“当时看来是个好主意”。我们今天节目的四幕，每一幕都以巨大的希望和一个闪亮的新点子开始。
Act One, Luck of the Irish. In that act, a bunch of people become very convinced that with one simple purchase, they can change their lives forever. Act Two, Taxation Without Inebriation. In that act, how to make a decision to hire somebody who absolutely, positively is going to do you no good-- and you can tell they're going to do you no good-- and why you may never fire that person.
第一幕，爱尔兰人的运气。在那一幕里，一群人变得非常确信，只要进行一次简单的购买，他们就能永远改变他们的生活。第二幕，无醉酒的征税。在那一幕里，如何做出决定去雇佣一个绝对、肯定对你没有任何好处的人——而且你能看出他们对你没有任何好处——以及为什么你可能永远不会解雇那个人。
Act Three, Bad Morning America. Davy Rothbart goes onto morning television and does a little experiment on his hosts. Act Four, The Function of the Heart. An 11-year-old girl comes up with a simple scheme on how she can finally get to really know her dad, her dad who is not so keen on being known. Stay with us.
第三幕，坏的美国早晨。戴维·罗斯巴特上了早间电视节目，对他的主持人们做了一个小实验。第四幕，心脏的功能。一个11岁的小女孩想出了一个简单的计划，关于她如何最终能真正了解她的爸爸，那个不太热衷于被了解的爸爸。请留下来。
Act One, Luck of the Irish. This first story takes place far from the New York police force. This is a very different kind of job, maybe about as different as you can get.
第一幕，爱尔兰人的运气。这第一个故事发生在远离纽约警察部队的地方。这是一种非常不同的工作，也许是你能想到的最不同的工作。
Well, I was in Riverdance. But I don't actually dance. I just sing. There's a lead female singer.
嗯，我在《大河之舞》里。但我其实并不跳舞。我只是唱歌。有一位女领唱。
It must be a terrible thing to be the singer in Riverdance because nobody actually-- it's all about the dancing, right?
做《大河之舞》的歌手一定很糟糕，因为没人真的——全都是关于跳舞的，对吧？
No, exactly. And every now and then, someone will say something like, it's called Riverdance, not Riversing.
不，完全正确。偶尔会有人说些什么，这叫《大河之舞》，不是《大河之唱》。
Mr. And Mrs. America, please meet Katie Else. Katie was touring with Riverdance, doing eight shows a week, working every day. Any day that they weren't on stage, they would be traveling.
美国先生和女士们，请认识一下凯蒂·埃尔斯。凯蒂正在随《大河之舞》巡演，每周表演八场，每天都在工作。任何他们不在舞台上的日子，他们都会在路上。
70 people in the company. That's four singers, a band, assorted tech guys and support people, and 40-- yes, 40-- dancers doing that Irish stepdancing thing they do. I don't even know if it's called stepdancing. You know what I'm talking about here? The Michael Flatley-- of course you do, because you've seen television.
剧团里有70个人。那是四个歌手，一个乐队，各种技术人员和支持人员，还有40个——是的，40个——跳那种他们跳的爱尔兰踢踏舞的舞者。我甚至不知道那是不是叫踢踏舞。你知道我在说什么吧？迈克尔·弗莱利——当然你知道，因为你看过电视。
Anyway, two months into the tour, a time when working every day, they're getting kind of tired with the monotony of working every day. And they needed some excitement. And this idea spread through the company like wildfire.
总之，巡演两个月后，在这个每天都在工作的时间里，他们对每天工作的单调感到有些厌倦了。他们需要一些兴奋。而这个想法像野火一样在剧团里蔓延开来。
I think it was the idea of the lead dancer and dance captain. He has this ridiculous luck with raffles. We have a raffle every Friday, and he has won it like five times. And he just has ridiculous luck with this.
我想是领舞和舞蹈队长的主意。他在抽奖方面有这种荒谬的运气。我们每周五都有抽奖，他已经赢了大概五次了。他在这方面运气好得离谱。
And he just happened to notice, on the internet I guess, that Mega-Millions had gotten up to like $360 million or something like that. So he suggested that we all do a syndicate ticket. It's like you pool your money. So $5 gets five tickets. But everybody has a share in all the tickets.
他刚好注意到，我想是在网上，超级百万彩票的奖金已经到了3.6亿美元左右。所以他建议我们大家都买一张联合彩票。就像你汇集你的钱。所以5美元可以买五张票。但每个人都分享所有票的份额。
Not to complicate it, right? They're playing the lottery. So the company's physical therapist, who's a guy named Scott, he is the one who organized the whole thing and collected everybody's money. And the reason why it's him is-- OK, if you picture this company of 40 dancers, it's like-- and I hate to bring up this analogy, but honestly it's very, very apt-- the Starship Enterprise.
不把事情复杂化，对吧？他们在买彩票。所以剧团的物理治疗师，一个叫斯科特的人，就是组织整个事情并收集每个人钱的人。之所以是他，是因为——好吧，如果你想象一下这40名舞者的剧团，它就像——而且我讨厌提起这个比喻，但老实说它非常、非常贴切——进取号星舰。
Remember this? I always thought that it was really a little weird that the one job besides actually flying around and exploring space, the one set that they bothered to build on this television show that wasn't actually adventure related, was the doctor's office. I mean of all the things, right? And basically, it's like that with Riverdance. Scott, the physical therapist, has a very big role behind the scenes in Riverdance.
记得这个吗？我一直觉得很奇怪，除了真的在太空飞来飞去探索之外，他们在这个电视节目里费心搭建的唯一不是关于冒险的场景，竟然是医生办公室。我是说在所有事物中，对吧？基本上，《大河之舞》也一样。物理治疗师斯科特在《大河之舞》的幕后扮演着非常重要的角色。
Well, his office is like a center for gossip, and people gather there during the show.
嗯，他的办公室就像一个八卦中心，人们在演出期间聚集在那里。
And how'd the pitch go? Give me the pitch.
那么这个推销是怎么进行的？把推销给我。
Well, he didn't-- it was just basically like, everybody's doing this. We want everybody to get involved. Because then our chances will be better, which is kind of a ridiculous thing to say when you're talking about the lottery because your chances are so slim. To be like, one more person.
嗯，他没有——基本上就像是，大家都在做这个。我们希望每个人都参与进来。因为那样我们的机会会更好，这在谈论彩票时是一种相当荒谬的说法，因为你的机会太渺茫了。就像说，多一个人。
But we figured out the stats. I guess the stats on the Mega-Millions at that point was 1 to 760 trillion. But we figured we had like a 340 to 760 trillion chance, which sounded better than one.
但我们算出了统计数据。我想当时超级百万彩票的统计数据是1比760万亿。但我们算了一下，我们大概有340比760万亿的机会，这听起来比1要好。
Because you guys would buy 340 tickets.
因为你们会买340张彩票。
Yeah.
是的。
But did it seem in some way reasonable? I'm sitting here, actually. And you're saying these numbers. And I'm writing out on a piece of paper 760. And I realize like, I don't even know-- wait. Is trillion the next one up from billion? And then I'm writing 340.
但这看起来在某种程度上合理吗？我正坐在那儿，实际上。而你在说这些数字。我正在纸上写下760。我意识到，比如，我甚至不知道——等等。万亿是十亿往上数的一级吗？然后我正在写340。
And then honestly, then you start to cross off a zero and a zero. And then you've got the 34 and the 76 and then a lot of zeros. And it just still seems like there's a lot of zeros there. (LAUGHING) You're still up in the kind of billions, aren't you, to 1?
然后老实说，你就开始划掉一个零和一个零。然后你剩下34和76，还有很多零。看起来仍然有很多零在那儿。（笑声）你仍然处于那种万亿级别，不是吗，对比1？
Yeah. I mean the chances are so unreasonable at that point, we just kind of forgot about the stats. I don't even know. I mean it just got unreasonable. We just thought for some reason if we focused all our energy on this, we were going to win it.
是的。我是说，到那个时候机会已经太不合理了，我们只是有点忘记了统计数据。我甚至不知道。我是说它变得不合理了。我们只是出于某种原因认为，如果我们把我们所有的能量集中在这上面，我们就能赢。
People even brought up theories of quantum physics and how we're all energy. And if we just focus our energy on winning this lottery, we'll be able to create our own destiny if that makes any sense.
人们甚至提出了量子物理学的理论，以及我们都是能量。如果我们只是把我们的能量集中在赢这个彩票上，我们就能够创造我们自己的命运，如果这有什么意义的话。
It does indeed, yeah. No, because when math fails, what do you have left but sheer faith?
确实如此，是的。不，因为当数学失败时，除了纯粹的信仰你还有什么呢？
Faith, yeah. There'd be dissenters. They would be like, you know, the chances of us winning this-- and we'd be like, no. No, no, no. You're the chink in the chain. We need to focus all our energy on winning the lottery.
信仰，是的。会有反对者。他们会说，你知道，我们赢这个的机会——我们会说，不。不，不，不。你是链条里的那个缺口。我们需要把我们所有的能量集中在赢彩票上。
And then it just became kind of like a group psychology thing, right? Like everybody's holding everybody else up.
然后它就变得有点像群体心理学了，对吧？就像每个人都在支持每个人。
Yeah. It's kind of bizarre how worked up you can get yourself. And one of the girls even said-- she had been reading Deepak Chopra, or something. And she was like, we can't say we're going to win the lottery. We have to say, we've won the lottery, and then we'll win.
是的。你能让自己变得那么兴奋真是太怪了。其中一个女孩甚至说——她一直在读迪帕克·乔普拉，或者类似的东西。她说，我们不能说我们要赢彩票。我们必须说，我们已经赢了彩票，然后我们就会赢。
How far did this go? They all started planning what they were going to do with the money. Katie, for example, was going to pay off her parents' house. She was going to buy a house for herself. She was going to put a little recording studio in the house for her singing career.
这到了什么程度？他们都开始计划赢了钱后要做什么。例如，凯蒂打算还清她父母房子的钱。她打算为自己买一栋房子。她打算在房子里放一个小型录音棚，为了她的歌唱事业。
And as they came closer to the night of the Mega-Millions drawing, a Tuesday night, it was clear what most of the cast wanted. I have to say it's kind of touching. It tells you so much about them and their lives, what it is that they wanted.
随着超级百万彩票开奖之夜——一个周二晚上——的临近，很明显剧团大多数人想要什么。我必须说这有点感人。它告诉了你很多关于他们和他们生活的事情，他们想要的是什么。
See, a lot of the people are quite young in the show. So they're like, I'm quitting Riverdance. I'm going to school. Everybody was quitting.
你看，剧团里很多人相当年轻。所以他们说，我要退出《大河之舞》。我要去上学。每个人都要退出。
All right. I'm going to stop that tape right there. Can I just say this is such a sad statement about the state of education funding in America that if you're young-- you're young. You're in your 20s.
好了。我要在那里停止磁带。我能说这对于美国教育经费状况是一个如此悲伤的声明吗，如果你年轻——你很年轻。你20多岁。
You think, OK, how can I get to college? What might be a good way that I might be able to finance that? What would be a good plan? And the plan that seems reasonable to you-- and not just to you, but to you and several dozen of your peers is "I'm going to play the lotto."
你想，好吧，我怎么才能上大学？什么可能是资助那个的好方法？什么会是一个好的计划？而那个对你来说似乎合理的计划——不仅仅是对你，而且是对你和几十个你的同龄人来说——是“我要去买彩票。”
Everybody was quitting. But we decided that we would stick out the rest of the tour because it would be a while before-- because at first people were like, this will be our last show. This will be our last show.
每个人都在退出。但我们决定我们将坚持巡演的剩余部分，因为那将需要一段时间——因为起初人们说，这将是我们的最后一场演出。这将是我们的最后一场演出。
We realized we wouldn't get the money for a while. And so we decided that we'd stick out the rest of the tour. And then I'll quit after that.
我们意识到我们有一段时间拿不到钱。所以我们决定我们将坚持完成巡演的其余部分。然后我之后就会退出。
Well, that's sporting of you to honor your commitment to Riverdance.
嗯，尊重你对《大河之舞》的承诺真是太有体育精神了。
Yeah, isn't it? Because we were just going to call our producer the next day and tell him we were done. Well, we also had a plan too, because we had a break a week later of a few days.
是的，不是吗？因为我们只是打算第二天给我们的制片人打电话告诉他我们不干了。嗯，我们也有个计划，因为一周后我们有个几天的休息。
And he's like, well, I'll just go pick up the money in Georgia during the break. I'll bring somebody else with me. And he's like, first things first, we've got to hire ourselves a lawyer. We had the whole game plan.
他说，嗯，我休息期间会去乔治亚州领钱。我会带别人跟我一起去。他说，第一件事，我们得雇个律师。我们有整个游戏计划。
That's important because, as anybody who's ever been to the movies knows, you have to have a game plan. Because somebody has to go with the physical therapist to Georgia to pick up the money. Or suddenly, you're in a whole Billy Bob Thornton movie where things are going wrong, and people are running off. And you definitely want to avoid that.
这很重要，因为，就像任何去过电影院的人都知道的那样，你必须有一个游戏计划。因为有人必须和物理治疗师一起去乔治亚州领钱。否则突然之间，你就进入了一部比利·鲍伯·松顿的电影，事情出了错，人们跑了。而你绝对想避免这种情况。
All right. This brings us to the big night. All right. Let me cue some big event music here. OK. Here we go.
好了。这把我们带到了那个大日子。好了。让我播放一些大事件音乐。好了。我们走吧。
[BIG EVENT MUSIC PLAYING]
[大事件音乐播放]
All right. It's the big night, Mega-Millions drawing, Tuesday night, a show night for them because every night is a show night. Backstage before the show, they all gather in a big huddle around the dance captain for what basically amounts to the Saint Crispin's Day speech from Henry V.
好了。这是大日子，超级百万彩票开奖，周二晚上，对他们来说是个演出之夜，因为每天晚上都是演出之夜。演出前在后台，他们都聚集在舞蹈队长周围大声密谋，这基本上相当于《亨利五世》里圣克里斯平日的演讲。
He kind of made this speech and said, we want you to put all your energy into this show. And maybe we can win this thing.
他某种程度上做了这个演讲，说，我们希望你把所有的能量都投入到这场演出中。也许我们能赢这个东西。
You mean while you're dancing, you're dancing--
你是说当你跳舞的时候，你在跳舞——
For the lottery.
为了彩票。
And you're focusing that dance at those little balls somewhere.
而且你把那个舞蹈聚焦在那些小球在某个地方。
Exactly.
完全正确。
You're sending that dancey energy through space.
你正在把那种舞蹈能量通过空间发送。
Yes, towards winning the lottery.
是的，朝着赢彩票的方向。
So it was sort of exciting.
所以这有点令人兴奋。
It was quite exciting. And I mean, we kind of got worked up into a frenzy almost. People were just going insane. There is one point where I actually dance. I dance for about 30 seconds. And we're kind of spinning in this circle in the middle. And usually you're kind of like yip, yoo, woo. But people were screaming. And they were yelling things like, do it for the lotto.
这相当令人兴奋。我是说，我们几乎变得狂热起来了。人们只是要疯了。有一点我确实跳舞。我跳了大约30秒。我们某种程度上在中间转圈。通常你就像耶，呦，呜。但人们在尖叫。他们在喊类似“为了彩票做吧”的话。
Do you think the audience could hear "do it for the lotto?"
你认为观众能听见“为了彩票做吧”吗？
I really hope not.
我真心希望没有。
I mean you can see why they would get so worked up about this. They had been working every day for two months, which actually brings us to one of the difficult things about doing theater, especially a show like Riverdance.
我是说你能看出他们为什么会对这个如此兴奋。他们两个月来每天都在工作，这实际上带出了做剧场，特别是像《大河之舞》这样的演出的困难点之一。
You have to find ways to break up the monotony of doing something like that. Because it's not even like you have a role to throw yourself into. And half of what I sing is nonsense anyway. So to have something else to add to the show or spice up the show I think helps a lot. Because otherwise, you can just easily just be going through the motions.
你必须找到打破像那样做事的单调的方法。因为这甚至不像你有角色可以全身心投入。我唱的一半东西本来就是废话。所以我觉得有一些别的东西加入演出或给演出加点料非常有帮助。因为否则，你很容易就只是在走过场。
That's right. I hadn't thought about that. It's actually a job where you don't get a day off. And every single day, you do exactly the same thing.
没错。我没想到那点。这实际上是一份你没有休息日的工作。而且每一天，你做的完全一样的事情。
Yes.
是的。
And exactly the same thing. It's not like other jobs where you're working a cash register, and it sort of seems like you're doing the same thing. But you're actually talking to different people, and you're doing this and that. But you're actually literally making exactly the same motions around the stage and uttering the same sounds out of your mouth. It's exactly the same every day.
完全一样的事情。这不像其他工作，比如你在收银台工作，看起来你好像在做同样的事情。但你实际上在和不同的人说话，你在做这个做那个。但你实际上在舞台上字面意思上做完全相同的动作，从嘴里发出完全相同的声音。每一天都完全一样。
Yeah. See, we try to find other ways to try to spice up the show. Like, OK, in this number, you have to do as many random 360-degree turns as you can.
是的。你看，我们尝试找到其他方式来给演出加点料。比如，好吧，在这个曲目里，你必须做尽可能多的随机360度旋转。
Really?
真的吗？
Yeah. Or, in this one, you have to do as many head twitches as you can fit in.
是的。或者，在这个曲目里，你必须做尽可能多的头部抽搐。
This is-- I don't know. This is just a universal thing with performing, I guess. I mean I feel like I-- even I, in my limited way, understand this. I, for our radio show, go out, and I visit public radio stations around the country and give these talks about our show in theaters.
这是——我不知道。这只是表演的一种普遍现象，我想。我是说我觉得我——即使我，以我有限的方式，也理解这一点。我，为了我们的广播节目，我会出去，访问全国各地的公共广播电台，在剧院里就我们的节目做这些演讲。
And years ago, when I first started doing this, the way that they would send me out is I would go out five or six nights in a row, like one city each night. And the thing that I learned is that I am not a good enough performer to say the same thing on stage five or six nights in a row and sound sincere, or even speak with any feeling at all. I have to do them weeks apart. And even then, it's best if I change the speech a little each time.
多年前，当我刚开始做这个的时候，他们派我出去的方式是我会连续五六个晚上出去，每天一个城市。我学到的是我不是一个足够好的表演者，不能连续五六个晚上在舞台上说同样的话而听起来真诚，甚至带任何感情。我必须把它们隔开几周。即使那样，如果我每次稍微改变一下演讲内容最好。
Otherwise, I find myself on stage talking about these things that mean so much to me, about our radio show and what we're trying to do. And I'm on stage, and I'll be talking. And it'll just feel like nothing, like nothing, like-- blah, blah, blah. Like gum that's been chewed for way too long.
否则，我会发现自己在舞台上谈论这些对我意义重大的事情，关于我们的广播节目以及我们试图做的事情。我在舞台上，我会说话。而它会感觉什么都没有，什么都没有，比如——吧，吧，吧。就像嚼了太久的口香糖。
And this is the thing about doing dance as a job, or any kind of performing-- music, or comedy, or acting. It's like once you turn it into a job, once it's a job, it means that every night, you have to get on stage and take something that means so much to you, that means the world to you, and you have to repeat it until it does not mean anything at all. So if you're somebody like Katie in a big professional touring production, you have to consciously do stuff to keep up your energy when you're on stage.
这就是把舞蹈作为工作，或者任何类型的表演——音乐，喜剧，或演戏的事情。就像一旦你把它变成了一份工作，一旦它是一份工作，这意味着每天晚上，你都必须上台，拿起某样对你意义重大的东西，对你意味着全世界的东西，然后你必须重复它直到它没有任何意义。所以如果你像凯蒂一样在大制作巡演中，你必须有意识地做些事情来在你上台时保持你的能量。
Sometimes if you're on stage, and the dancers are dancing, and I'm not singing, I'll just be talking to people.
有时如果你在台上，舞者在跳舞，我不在唱歌，我只是在和人们聊天。
(LAUGHING) Talking to people. Smoking a cigarette. You get a cell phone call.
（笑声）和人们聊天。抽一支烟。你接到一个手机电话。
Excuse me. I have to take this. No. But I know. And I feel bad in the same regard with the audience when we perform. And they think you're giving them all this energy and this amazing performance. And you're really just like, where are we going to go tonight? What are we going to do?
抱歉。我得接这个。不。但我知道。在观众面前我也同样感到愧疚。他们认为你正在给他们所有的这些能量和这场精彩的表演。而你其实只是在想，我们今晚去哪儿？我们要干什么？
Though, on the night of the big Mega-Millions drawing, that was definitely not a problem.
虽然，在超级百万彩票开奖的大日子那天，那绝对不是问题。
The audience was really reacting to the amount of energy that we were putting out. They were going nuts. They'd be breaking out into applause in the middle of numbers. And just the amount of volume coming from the audience, you could just tell.
观众确实在回应我们投入的所有能量。他们疯了。他们在曲目中间爆发热烈的掌声。单单来自观众的音量，你就能感觉出来。
Definitely the best show on tour. So much energy we were giving them, but it was because we wanted to win the lottery. It wasn't because we necessarily wanted to give them a really good show. It's because we were greedy.
绝对是巡演中最棒的一场演出。我们给了他们太多的能量，但这因为我们想赢彩票。那不是因为我们一定要给他们一场真正精彩的演出。这是因为我们贪婪。
Was it the actual best night of Riverdance you ever were in?
那是你参与过的最棒的《大河之舞》之夜吗？
Yeah. At the end of the show, I almost felt like I was on some kind of crazy drug. Because I was like, yes, do it for the lottery. You'd gotten yourself so worked up at that point. At least for me, I've never had so much energy on stage. I'm usually a little bit lethargic and just kind of-- I basically just kind of stroll around, turn my head out to the audience, and sing.
是的。在演出结束时，我几乎觉得我好像吃了某种疯狂的药。因为我当时想，是的，为了彩票做吧。你那时已经让自己变得太兴奋了。至少对我来说，我在台上从来没这么有能量过。我通常有点嗜睡，只是某种程度上的——我基本上只是随便溜达，把头转向观众，唱歌。
So they come off stage. It's 10:15, 10:20, something like that. And it's like they are stoned. They are buzzing. They are totally hyped up. And the lottery's at 11:00. And they gather at the hotel bar.
所以他们下台了。大概10:15，10:20左右。就像他们嗑药了一样。他们嗡嗡作响。他们完全兴奋起来了。而彩票是11点。他们聚集在酒店酒吧。
And Scott, the physical therapist, actually went to the trouble to type the numbers of all their lottery tickets out onto a page, which he duplicated and handed copies to everybody. So that's all over the bar. And he also had the original tickets sealed neatly in these little plastic bags in numerical order. Such care.
物理治疗师斯科特甚至费心把他们所有彩票的号码打在一张纸上，他复印了并分发给每个人。所以酒吧到处都是。他还有密封得整整齐齐的原始彩票放在这些小塑料袋里，按数字顺序排列。真是细心。
And pretty much everybody was there. We're at a bunch of different tables. And every table has a different computer printout to read over the lottery numbers. So we get the numbers. And we're just poring over these sheets. And we're just getting nothing, nothing, not even anything remotely close.
基本上每个人都在那儿。我们在不同的桌子。每一张桌子都有不同的电脑打印输出阅读彩票号码。所以我们拿到了号码。我们只是在仔细阅读这些纸张。我们什么都没得到，什么都没有，甚至没有什么接近的。
Wow.
哇。
So then someone's like, I want to see the originals. What if you made a mistake in the computer? So we're going through the originals and collectively--
所以然后有人说，我想看原件。如果你在电脑里犯错了呢？所以我们正在检查原件，集体地——
Yeah. I love the instinct of that, though. The instinct is, this must be wrong. I mean clearly we won.
是的。我喜欢那种直觉。直觉是，这肯定是错的。我的意思是显然我们赢了。
Exactly.
完全正确。
There's been some sort of mistake here.
这里肯定有什么错误。
He made a mistake. But it wasn't even like there was one that was close. And someone actually brought up-- someone actually posed the idea that maybe Scott had put the numbers in wrong, and we had won the lottery. He had won the lottery and was going to take all the money.
他犯了个错误。但甚至没有一个是接近的。有人甚至提出来——有人实际上提出了这个想法，也许斯科特把号码输入错了，我们已经赢了彩票。他赢了彩票，打算把钱全拿走。
Wow.
哇。
It's amazing how worked up you can get yourself, and especially-- it's like gang mentality-- how worked up you can get each other. And then you just crash.
你能让自己变得多兴奋真是太不可思议了，尤其是——就像黑帮心理——你们能互相把对方煽动到什么程度。然后你只是崩溃。
Nobody even hung around, she said. They all went straight to bed. And the next day, they did a lousy show, incredibly low energy.
她说，没人留下来。他们都直接去睡觉了。第二天，他们做了一场烂透了的演出，能量极低。
And here's the disturbing thing. The audience loved it. Couldn't tell at all, which either means that A, they are such solid performers and this material, the Riverdance material, is so solid that even on their worst day, they are pretty damn good.
这是令人不安的事情。观众很喜欢。完全看不出来，这意味着要么A，他们是如此可靠的表演者，而这部材料，《大河之舞》的材料，是如此稳固，以至于即使在他们最糟糕的一天，他们也相当棒。
Or B-- and this is kind of ugly to say, but I'm just going to say it. When you and I and a lot of people, when we get together in a mass group, and we get together in an audience, and we're sitting in the theater in an audience, we just get stupid. And it doesn't matter if the performers try. Katie actually sees it somewhere in between those two.
或者B——这话说出来有点丑陋，但我还是会说出来。当你和我以及很多人，当我们聚在一起成一个大群体，当我们聚在一起成为观众，我们坐在剧院里成为观众，我们只是变傻了。而表演者是否努力并不重要。凯蒂实际上看到了介于两者之间的地方。
They're going to see kind of what they want to see. They came wanting to see this thing. They think you're giving them all this energy and this amazing performance. And that's what they're going to see.
他们去看某种他们想看的东西。他们来是因为想要看到这个东西。他们认为你正在给他们所有的这些能量和这场精彩的表演。那就是他们要看的。
Which in a way is just people being nice, assuming the performers are doing their best onstage. You know? We want to laugh at the comedian's jokes. We want them to be funny. It's a nice thing. This whole experience raised some very basic questions about performing.
这在某种程度上只是人们表现得友善，假设表演者在台上尽力而为。你知道吗？我们想对喜剧演员的笑话发笑。我们想让他们很有趣。这是一件好事。整个经历引发了一些关于表演的非常基本的问题。
And in theory, I guess-- we were talking. We were like, you know, I guess that's how much energy you're supposed to give the audience, ideally, every night. But you can't. Like I couldn't do-- after we lost the lottery, obviously, I turned to one of my friends. And I was like, I don't think I could do another lotto show. I don't think it would be possible. It's just too draining.
在理论上，我想——我们在交谈。我们就像，你知道，我想这就是你理想中每晚应该给观众的能量。但你不能。比如我不能做——在我们输掉彩票后，显然，我转向我的一个朋友。我就说，我不认为我能再做一场彩票秀。我不认为那是可能的。这只是太消耗了。
Because I would think it's more fun to perform if you're more hyped up. You know?
因为我认为如果你更兴奋，表演会更有趣。你知道吗？
It definitely is more fun. It kind of puts performing in perspective because-- I don't know. Maybe some people just get themselves really hyped up and can do that every night. And good for them. But eight shows a week, that's a lot of shows. I don't think I could.
这绝对更有趣。这让表演更有视角感，因为——我不知道。也许有些人只是让自己变得非常兴奋并且能够每晚都那样做。为他们高兴。但每周八场演出，那可是很多演出。我不认为我能。
One of the conclusions that you all could come to is that, although you were dancing your hardest and trying to direct that energy towards the Powerball, perhaps that isn't really what determines how the Powerball falls.
你们所有人可能得出的结论之一是，尽管你们在最卖力地跳舞并试图把那份能量指向强力球，也许那并不是真正决定强力球如何掉落的东西。
Perhaps.
也许。
Well, or possibly you weren't dancing quite hard enough.
嗯，或者可能你跳得不够卖力。
Yeah.
是的。
Or there was a touring company of Chicago that really danced.
或者有一个芝加哥的巡演剧团真的跳了舞。
Well, I think the people who ended up winning was-- it was another syndicate ticket, but it was nurses. So I don't know what they did. They put as much energy into changing bedpans and putting in IVs as they could.
嗯，我认为最终赢了的人是——那是另一张联合彩票，但那是护士。所以我不知道她们做了什么。她们把尽可能多的能量投入到了换便盆和输液中。
Or saving lives.
或者拯救生命。
One little dance troupe can't compete with that, man.
一个小舞团竞争不过那个，老兄。
No.
不。
They get in there, and they save a couple lives for the lottery. That's some energy.
她们进去，她们为彩票拯救了几条生命。那是能量。
That's true. I bet they saved a life. Damn it.
那是真的。我打赌她们救了一条命。该死。
Singer Katie Else. Since doing this interview, she's quit Riverdance. She has an album coming out. Info at katieelse.com.
歌手凯蒂·埃尔斯。自从做完这次采访，她已经退出了《大河之舞》。她有一张专辑要发行。信息在katieelse.com。
[MUSIC - "LOTTERY" BY MARKY RAMONE AND THE INTRUDERS]
[音乐 - "LOTTERY" BY MARKY RAMONE AND THE INTRUDERS]
Act Two, Taxation Without Inebriation. So you need help. You're in over your head, and you turn to a professional. Often, that is a good idea. It just depends on who the professional is that you turn to. A couple years ago, Joel Lovell and his wife had financial problems. Tax time was coming around. And for once, he says, they got the bright idea to take appropriate steps.
第二幕，无醉酒的征税。所以你需要帮助。你力不从心，你求助于专业人士。通常，那是个好主意。这取决于你求助的是谁。几年前，乔尔·洛维尔和他的妻子有经济问题。报税时间快到了。他说，他们难得有了采取适当措施的好主意。
The first time we went to see Len, he spent an hour and a half talking about movies and musicals and the actors he'd had as clients way back when nobody knew their names. "F. Murray Abraham owes me," he said. "I've saved his ass for years."
我们第一次去见伦的时候，他花了一个半小时谈论电影和音乐剧，以及他在没人知道他们名字时曾作为客户的演员们。“F·默里·亚伯拉罕欠我的人情，”他说。“我多年来拯救了他的屁股。”
Eventually, my wife Kate cut in and explained that we were pretty worried, that the bulk of our income that year had been untaxed, and that we hadn't paid any quarterly estimates. Kate made most of her living then as an improv actor, and I made most of mine as a freelance writer. And the truth was we'd spent everything we'd earned and more.
最终，我的妻子凯特插话解释说我们非常担心，那一年的大部分收入都没有纳税，而且我们没有支付任何季度预估税。凯特当时大部分时间是作为即兴演员谋生，而我大部分时间是作为自由撰稿人。事实是我们已经花光了我们赚的所有钱，甚至更多。
Len looked at us incredulously. "Can one of you explain to me," he said, "how the hell Ordinary People beats out Raging Bull? Does that make a lick of freaking sense?" It's a little hard to explain now. But at the time, it seemed charming rather than worrisome that our accountant was more concerned about what won best picture in 1980 than about our unpaid taxes.
伦难以置信地看着我们。“你们中谁能向我解释，”他说，“《普通人》到底是怎么打败《愤怒的公牛》的？这他妈的有哪怕一点道理吗？”现在解释起来有点难。但在当时，我们的会计师更关心1980年什么电影赢得了最佳影片，而不是我们未缴纳的税款，这看起来很迷人，而不是令人担忧。
On the subway ride from Len's Manhattan apartment back to Brooklyn, I went on and on about how reassuring it was to take our financial mess to a guy like him. His whole attitude was comforting, I kept saying. Even the fact that he was drunk while we sat there in his office, it helped put things in perspective.
在从伦的曼哈顿公寓回布鲁克林的地铁上，我不停地谈论把我们的财务烂摊子交给像他这样的人是多么令人安心。他整个态度很令人安慰，我不断地说。即使是我们坐在他的办公室里时他喝醉了的事实，也有助于把事情看清楚。
When we got home, there were three messages on our answering machine, each one more slurred than the one that had come before it. "It's Len," the first message started. "You kids are screwed. I'll do what I can, but this is a horror show. You should know that." Then a beep and, "It's me, Len. I don't know what the hell we're going to do here."
当我们回到家时，我们的答录机上有三条留言，每一条都比前一条更含糊不清。“我是伦，”第一条留言开始了。“你们这些孩子完蛋了。我会尽我所能，但这简直是个恐怖片。你们应该知道。”然后是一声哔声，然后是，“是我，伦。我不知道我们他妈的要在这里做什么。”
And finally this-- which we had to play over a few times to understand. "Kate, you're a comedienne, for Christ's sake. If you go out to drinks with Steve Martin, you can-- you can write that off. That sort of crap, that's legit." Kate, who had never met Steve Martin, stared at the answering machine for some time. Eventually, she looked up at me and said, "We can't ever go to Len again."
最后是这个——我们不得不重播了几次才能听懂。“凯特，看在上帝份上，你是个喜剧演员。如果你和史蒂夫·马丁出去喝酒，你可以——你可以把那记入费用。那种破事，是合法的。”从未见过史蒂夫·马丁的凯特盯着答录机看了好一会儿。最终，她抬头看着我说，“我们再也不能去找伦了。”
The next year, I went to Len again. I know it doesn't make any sense. I knew it even then. But the thing was he saved us a ton of money. And while he did it in a way that was not technically legal, he made it all seem perfectly justified.
第二年，我又去找了伦。我知道这根本说不通。我当时甚至也知道。但问题是他为我们节省了一大笔钱。虽然他做的方式从技术上讲不合法，但他让这一切看起来完全正当。
When I went to pick up our return and paused for a moment over some figures that were utterly fictional, Len scoffed at me. "Look," he said. "They want to screw you. And I'll lie up the "waz" to make sure you don't get screwed. [BLEEP] them. That's how you have to think about these things."
当我去取我们的报税表，在一些完全虚构的数字上停顿了一会儿时，伦对我嗤之以鼻。“看，”他说。“他们想坑你。为了确保你不被坑，我会胡说八道到极致的。[消音]他们。这就是你必须看待这些事情的方式。”
It was more than just the money, though. There was something-- I don't know-- kind of cool about having a tax preparer who couldn't have had less regard for the government's rules. Len did the taxes of artists and writers and actors. And the thing he valued about them had nothing to do with their money. At a time when a few of my friends had become suddenly, inexplicably rich, just sitting in Len's shambles of an office, looking at his albums and books, at the paintings and sculptures he'd accepted from clients in lieu of actual payment, it made me feel like I was a part of this creative community.
不过，这不仅仅是关于钱。有一些——我不知道——有点酷，拥有一个对政府规定毫不理会的报税员。伦处理艺术家、作家和演员的税。他看重他们的东西与他们的钱无关。当时，我的一些朋友突然变得不可思议地富有，仅仅是坐在伦那乱七八糟的办公室里，看着他的相册和书，看着他从客户那里接受的代替实际支付的绘画和雕塑，这让我觉得我是这个创意社区的一部分。
It was about 10:00 in the morning when I saw Len, a week before the filing deadline. And he was chain-smoking Parliaments and drinking scotch from a stainless steel tumbler. His desk was covered with manila folders, dozens of them. They were coffee ringed and cigarette stained, his calculations scratched across them in a tiny, illegible hand. There was a drum kit in the corner of the room piled high with even more folders. And next to Len's desk on a metal cart was a computer that looked like it had just come out of the box.
报税截止日期前一周，我见到伦的时候大约是早上10点。他正连环抽着议会牌香烟，从不锈钢杯里喝着苏格兰威士忌。他的办公桌上满是马尼拉文件夹，几十个。它们上面有咖啡圈和香烟渍，他的计算结果用一种微小、难以辨认的字体写在上面。房间角落里有一套鼓，上面堆着更多的文件夹。伦的桌子旁边是一辆金属小车，上面有一台看起来刚从盒子里拿出来的电脑。
"They told me this freaking program would make it easier," Len said. "But I don't know what the hell." He looked exhausted and distracted. "There's this kid they keep sending over to help me out, but everything he says just confuses me more."
“他们告诉我这个该死的程序会让事情变得更容易，”伦说。“但我不知道他妈的怎么用。”他看起来精疲力竭且心烦意乱。“他们一直派来帮我的那个孩子，但他说的每一句话只会让我更困惑。”
He slouched in his chair and rubbed his fists in tight circles around his eyes, then gave his head a little shake. "Ah, crap," he said. "Your old lady's a kick in the pants. She's a funny chick. I'm sorry she's not here." He started to chuckle, but the chuckle turned into a coughing fit. And Len hacked away for a solid half a minute, waving me off with one hand and resting his forehead on the edge of his desk.
他瘫坐在椅子里，用拳头在眼睛周围紧紧地画圈，然后头稍微摇了摇。“啊，该死，”他说。“你的老太婆很带劲。她是个有趣的妞。我很遗憾她不在这儿。”他开始咯咯笑，但笑声变成了咳嗽。伦咳嗽了整整半分钟，一只手把我挥开，前额靠在桌子边缘。
Eventually, a tremendously thin and wrinkled woman appeared in the door. "You OK, Lenny?" she asked. He lifted his head. "Yeah, good," he said. And the blood began to slowly retreat from his face. The woman handed him a handkerchief.
最终，一个非常瘦弱、满脸皱纹的女人出现在门口。“你还好吗，伦尼？”她问道。他抬起头。“是的，很好，”他说。血液开始慢慢地从他的脸上退去。那个女人递给他一条手帕。
And Len pulled a wad of crumpled bills out of his breast pocket. "Go buy us some steaks," he said. "Wine too if there's anything left over." Then he looked at me and smiled. "My ex," he said, "she's helping me out of a jam here."
伦从胸前口袋里掏出一叠皱巴巴的钞票。“去给我们买点牛排，”他说。“如果还剩点钱，买点酒。”然后他看着我笑了。“我的前妻，”他说，“她在这儿帮我摆脱困境。”
I nodded and held on to my folder filled with another year's bad news. I said something about how great it was that they could still work together, he and his ex, especially under the gun like this. "Yeah, we've been through it," he said. And then he went on to tell me about how the two of them went on this trip to Puerto Rico years ago, shortly after they were married.
我点点头，紧紧抓着我装满又一年坏消息的文件夹。我说了一些关于他们还能一起工作，他和他的前妻，尤其是在这种紧迫关头，真是太棒了。 “是的，我们已经经历过了，”他说。然后他继续告诉我他们俩在结婚后不久是如何去波多黎各旅行的。
"We drank rum drinks and sat around burning our asses off all week. It was great. On the last day, we barely had two nickels to rub together. So this is what we did. We went down to the pool for a few last drinks-- you know, just left all our crap in our room, right? Then caught a cab to the airport and got on the plane with nothing but our towels and sandals."
“我们喝着朗姆酒饮料，整个星期坐在那儿烧我们的屁股。太棒了。在最后一天，我们几乎连两枚镍币都凑不到一起。所以这就是我们做的。我们下楼到游泳池去喝最后几杯——你知道，只是把我们所有的烂东西留在了房间里，对吧？然后打车去机场，只带着我们的毛巾和凉鞋上了飞机。”
He started laughing again, hard. And I braced myself for another coughing fit, but it didn't come. "Ah, Christ," he said. "Those were good days. You could do stuff like that back then." I just sat there trying to take in what that meant. 30 years ago, you could check into a hotel in Puerto Rico for a week, then not pay and leave all your belongings in your room, then go to the airport in your swim trunks and fly back to New York City?
他又开始大笑起来。我做好准备迎接又一次咳嗽，但没来。“啊，上帝，”他说。“那是些好日子。那时你可以做那种事情。”我只是坐在那儿试图领会这意味着什么。30年前，你可以入住波多黎各的一家酒店一个星期，然后不付钱，把你所有的个人物品留在房间里，然后穿着游泳裤去机场飞回纽约市？
While I considered this, Len pulled himself upright and surveyed the mess on his desk. He let out a long, dramatic sigh and said, "Ah, crap. There's no use putting it off any longer, right? Let's have the mess." I thought of my wife, the funny chick, back home in Brooklyn. She was really tired of us being jackasses about money, and I couldn't believe that she'd look kindly on this scene.
当我考虑这一点时，伦坐直了身子，环顾桌子上的乱摊子。他长长地叹了口气，戏剧性地说，“啊，该死。再拖下去也没用，对吧？把烂摊子拿来吧。”我想起了我的妻子，那个有趣的妞，回到布鲁克林的家里。她真的厌倦了我们在钱的问题上像个蠢驴，我不相信她会喜欢这个场景。
"I don't know, Len," I said. "It looks like you have your hands full this year. Why don't I take all this to someone else this time?" "Just give me the freaking folder," Len said. I started to make an excuse. But before I could get anything out of my mouth, Len heaved himself out of his chair and fell across the width of his desk.
“我不知道，伦，”我说。“看起来你今年够忙的了。为什么我不这次把这些带给别人？”“只要把该死的文件夹给我，”伦说。我开始找借口。但在我能从嘴里说出什么之前，伦把自己从椅子上费力地挪起来，扑在桌子上。
He grabbed my folder with one of his hands, and I watched his face go crimson. "Come on," he said. "I need this." I let go. Len fell back into his chair with my folder in his hands and closed his eyes. I knew I shouldn't leave it at this. That I needed to stand up, and maybe get a little mean and self-righteous, and tell him to give me my folder, and then walk out of there.
他用一只手抓住了我的文件夹，我看着他的脸变得通红。“来吧，”他说。“我需要这个。”我放手了。伦手里拿着我的文件夹倒回椅子里，闭上了眼睛。我知道我不应该就此罢手。我需要站起来，也许变得刻薄和自以为是，告诉他把我的文件夹给我，然后离开那儿。
But I couldn't. I'd like to believe that it was out of some sort of compassion. That I was looking at a broken man and choosing not to break him further. And maybe that was part of it. But it also had something to do with my own private disgrace at how little money I had and at how badly I managed it.
但我做不到。我想相信那是出于某种同情心。我看着一个破碎的人，选择不再进一步摧毁他。也许那是其中的一部分。但这也与我对自己有多少钱以及我管理得有多糟糕的私下羞耻有关。
It felt to me like it was just a facet of something larger and more troublesome, an inability to take much of anything very seriously. Without Len, I'd have to show that folder to someone else who'd probably look down on me. Len was less my accountant than the guardian of my shame. And in that respect, I still needed his services.
我觉得这只是更大、更麻烦的事情的一个侧面，即无法非常认真地对待很多事情。没有伦，我就得把那个文件夹拿给别人看，他们可能会瞧不起我。伦与其说是我的会计，不如说是我的羞耻感的守护者。在那方面，我仍然需要他的服务。
So I said OK, and walked out and waited for the elevator. When it arrived, Len's ex-wife stepped off with their steaks and wine. We smiled at each other, embarrassed. And she said, he'll be better next year. This one's a toughie.
所以我说了好，然后走了出去，等着电梯。当它到达时，伦的前妻带着他们的牛排和酒走了出来。我们互相微笑，感到尴尬。她说，他明年会好起来的。这个是一个难题。
Len never called us to sign our return. I assumed he'd filed for an extension. And I called him a few times and left messages trying to find out, though I didn't try very hard. Several months later, we received a letter telling us that Len had died in April, days before the filing deadline.
伦从没打电话让我们签署我们的报税表。我以为他申请了延期。我打过几次电话给他，留言想了解情况，虽然我没怎么认真打。几个月后，我们收到一封信，告诉我们伦在四月份死了，就在报税截止日期前几天。
I called the accountant who'd sent the letter. And he told me they had taken over a bunch of Len's clients. Our return had never been filed, he said. My wife and I owed a lot of money. He'd do what he could to explain the circumstances, but there were going to be some fines and penalties to pay. I understood that, right?
我打电话给发信的那位会计师。他告诉我他们接管了伦的一大堆客户。我们的报税表从未提交过，他说。我和我妻子欠了很多钱。他会尽力解释情况，但会有一些罚款和罚金要付。我理解这一点，对吧？
I thanked him, and hung up, and called the IRS. "I know I should have done something," I found myself admitting to a woman who repeatedly insisted that I and no one else was responsible for my taxes. I know I should have taken care of it differently.
我谢了他，挂断电话，给美国国税局打了电话。“我知道我本应该做点什么的，”我发现自己向一位一再坚持我以及除了我之外没有人对我的税负责的女士承认道。我知道我本应该用不同的方式处理它。
And then I thought of the bulk of Len's body on top of his desk, the wad of bills he handed to his ex-wife, the thousands of dollars we owed that we couldn't possibly pay. I imagined that figure circled in marker, sitting on the pile in Len's office after he died. "Can you tell me?" I asked her because I genuinely wanted to know. "Can you tell me how someone else would have handled this?"
然后我想到了伦的身体大半压在桌子上的样子，他递给他前妻的一叠钞票，我们欠的成千上万的我们不可能偿还的钱。我想象着那个数字在马克笔下画了个圈，在他死后放在伦办公室的堆里。“你能告诉我吗？”我问她，因为我真心想知道。“你能告诉我别人会怎么处理这个吗？”
Joel Lovell, he's no longer a freelancer. Now he's the executive editor at Pineapple Street Media.
乔尔·洛维尔，他不再是自由撰稿人了。现在他是Pineapple Street Media的执行主编。
[MUSIC - "LEN" BY COLIN MACINTYRE]
[音乐 - "LEN" BY COLIN MACINTYRE]
Coming up, can garbage be a force for justice? That's in a minute on Chicago Public Radio when our program continues.
接下来，垃圾能成为正义的力量吗？那是我们节目在芝加哥公共电台继续时，一分钟后。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Every week on our program, of course, we choose some theme and bring you a variety of different kinds of stories on that theme. Today's show, "Seemed Like a Good Idea at the Time," we've arrived at Act Three of our show. Act Three, Bad Morning America.
这是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。每周我们的节目，当然，我们选择一个主题，带给你在这个主题上的各种不同种类的故事。今天的节目，“当时看来是个好主意”，我们已经到达了节目的第三幕。第三幕，坏的美国早晨。
But every so often it actually happens-- the idea that seems so good at the time actually is. Kind of. Which brings us to Davy Rothbart's story. Davy's been on our show before. He's the creator of Found Magazine, where he publishes notes and scraps of paper and pictures just kind of randomly discovered by people on the street or wherever.
但每隔一段时间它真的发生了——那个当时看来很好的主意确实是好的。某种程度上。这把我们带到了戴维·罗斯巴特的故事。戴维以前上过我们的节目。他是Found Magazine的创造者，他在那里出版了人们在街上或任何地方随机发现的笔记和纸条和照片。
A couple years ago, Davy was promoting a book based on the same material. He was on this book tour that went to 136 cities. And in a lot of these cities, he did the local morning TV shows. This story he's about to tell was recorded in front of a live audience. Some of the names of cities and people have been changed.
几年前，戴维正在推销一本基于同样材料的书。他进行了这次去了136个城市的书籍巡演。而在很多这些城市，他做了当地的晨间电视节目。他要讲的这个故事是在现场观众面前录制的。一些城市和人的名字被更改了。
Early on in the tour, I took these gigs pretty seriously. But by the third week of the trip, I was starting to wonder who exactly, if anyone, was watching the local news at 7:00 AM. Also, while a couple of the hosts of these shows were real cool and genuinely excited about the book, most of them didn't get the whole idea behind it.
在巡演早期，我相当认真地对待这些演出。但到了旅行的第三周，我开始怀疑到底是谁，如果有的话，在早上7点看当地新闻。另外，虽然这些节目的一两个主持人真的很酷，并且对书真正感到兴奋，但他们大多数人并没有理解书背后的整个想法。
For some reason, this only increased their chipper-ness. "Those pants are so fun," they'd say, looking me up and down. "Plaid pants. You're fun, huh?"
出于某种原因，这只会增加他们的快乐程度。“那些裤子真有趣，”他们会说，上下打量我。“格子裤。你很有趣，对吧？”
The one thing that kept me excited about these morning TV gigs was getting to meet and hang out with my other fellow guests. These were local chefs with recipes of the week, mayoral candidates, a team of Irish dancers, a kid with an 80-pound pumpkin. On Fox 45's Good Morning Baltimore I did my little song and dance, and then the anchor asked me to stay on her couch while she brought out the next guest, Baltimore's best mom, an 87-year-old woman named Darnelda Cole. She sat next to me on the couch. And on the far side of her sat her 50-year-old son Dice.
让我对这些晨间电视节目感到兴奋的一件事是可以见到并和我其他同行嘉宾相处。这些是带每周食谱的当地厨师，市长候选人，一个爱尔兰舞蹈队，一个带着80磅南瓜的孩子。在福克斯45频道的《早安巴尔的摩》，我做了我的小歌舞，然后主持人要求我留在她的沙发上，当她请出下一位嘉宾时，巴尔的摩最好的妈妈，一位名叫达内尔达·科尔的87岁老妇人。她坐在沙发上我旁边。而在她远端坐着她50岁的儿子骰子。
Darnelda had no idea why she'd been asked to come on TV. They'd plotted this as a surprise. The anchor asked Dice Cole to read the letter he'd written. Darnelda grew weepy.
达内尔达根本不知道为什么她被要求上电视。他们把这策划为一个惊喜。主持人要求骰子·科尔读他写的信。达内尔达变得泪流满面。
At last, the anchor declared Darnelda Baltimore's Best Mom and produced an oversized plaque from somewhere and presented it to her, at which point Darnelda fell sobbing into my arms. I gave her a wild bear hug, caught up in the moment. A moment later, the anchorwoman joined our embrace.
最后，主持人宣布达内尔达是巴尔的摩最好的妈妈，从某处拿出一块超大的牌匾并呈现给她，在那一点上，达内尔达啜泣着倒进了我的怀抱。我给了她一个狂野的熊抱，陷入了那一刻。片刻之后，女主持人加入了我们的拥抱。
Dice, meanwhile, had lit up a cigarette, which an alarmed producer raced over and doused with a splash of sparkling water. Darnelda took this in and began hollering at her son and whacking him with her new plaque. "Dice, you can't smoke in here. This is TV we're making. Put that damn thing out."
骰子，与此同时，点燃了一支香烟，一位惊恐的制片人跑过来，用喷洒的水浇灭了它。达内尔达接受了这一点，并开始冲着她的儿子大喊，用她的新牌匾抽他。“骰子，你不能在这里吸烟。我们正在制作电视节目。把那个该死的东西弄灭。”
There were other high points. And by high points, I mean low points for the stations and their guests. In Cleveland, two city parks employees showed off an injured hawk and falcon they'd rescued.
还有其他高光时刻。而说高光时刻，我是说电视台及其嘉宾的低谷。在克利夫兰，两名城市公园员工展示了一只他们营救出来的受伤的老鹰和猎鹰。
Then the falcon got loose and started flapping about, peeing on everything. The anchors had to forge on through the local news and sports and weather while the falcon continued to dive-bomb them, rationing its urine so it could drip a few drops on them with every sortie. It was [BLEEP] amazing.
然后猎鹰挣脱了，开始拍打着四处乱飞，在所有东西上撒尿。主持人们不得不在当地新闻、体育和天气中坚持下去，而猎鹰继续俯冲轰炸他们，配给它的尿液，以便它可以在每次突击时滴几滴在他们身上。这简直[消音]太神奇了。
In Chicago, a young soccer champ demonstrating his fancy moves booted a ball off the wall of the set, knocking it over backwards-- revealing the fact that we were not actually in the host's living room, as it might appear, but in the middle of a big, dank, concrete hangar. In Phoenix, I was sandwiched on air between Cedric the Entertainer and the governor of Arizona. Cedric came on right before me, dropped a couple F-bombs, and then sheepishly left, telling his chaperone, "I didn't mean to say that [BLEEP]. It just came out, I swear to God."
在芝加哥，一位展示他花哨动作的年轻足球冠军把球踢出了布景的墙，把它向后撞倒——揭示了这样一个事实：我们实际上并不在主持人客厅，尽管看起来可能那样，而是在一个巨大的、阴冷的、混凝土机库中间。在凤凰城，我在直播中被夹在塞德里克娱乐和亚利桑那州州长中间。塞德里克在我之前出现，说了几个F开头词，然后羞怯地离开了，告诉他的护送人，“我不是故意要说那个[消音]的。它只是出来了，我向上帝发誓。”
I was traveling with my little brother in a van I'd bought off eBay. Often, we would do a Found event in one city, take turns driving all night to the next one, and get to the TV station parking lot around 4:00 AM. I could get a couple hours of sleep before it was time for me to unfold myself, "plomp" inside all rumpled and bleary-eyed, and do my thing for 90 seconds on air.
我带着我弟弟在一个我从eBay上买的货车里旅行。通常，我们会做一场Found活动在一个城市，轮流开车整夜去下一个，并在早上4点左右到达电视台停车场。我可以睡几个小时，然后在需要我把自己展开，“啪”地一声进去，浑身皱巴巴，睡眼惺忪，在直播中做我90秒钟的事情。
In the wee hours, security guards in the station lots would poke flashlights in our van windows and roust us. And I'd explain that I was going to be a guest on the morning show. And they'd disappear for 20 minutes to check into it, then come back and wake us again to tell us that things had checked out and everything was cool.
在凌晨时分，车站停车场的保安会用手电筒戳进我们的车窗，把我们赶起来。我会解释我要成为晨间节目的嘉宾。他们会消失20分钟去查证，然后回来再次把我们叫醒，告诉我们事情已经核实，一切都酷。
In Seattle, after a young security guard played this game with us, I asked him if I could come inside to use the john. We ended up talking for a while. His name was Pico. It turned out that the station was moving soon to brand-new, larger digs and that Pico was going to be replaced by an automatic gate with a swipe card.
在西雅图，在一名年轻保安和我们玩了这个游戏后，我问他我能否进去使用厕所。我们最终聊了一会儿。他的名字是皮科。原来电视台很快要搬到全新的、更大的地方，而皮科要被一个带刷卡卡的自动门取代。
Pico asked why I was going to be on the morning show. And I explained to him the Found book, all notes and letters and photos that folks around the country had found and sent in to us, little scraps that gave a glimpse into the lives of strangers. Pico got excited.
皮科问我为什么我要参加晨间节目。我向他解释了Found书，所有全国各地的人发现并寄给我们的笔记和信件和照片，揭示陌生人生活的小纸条。皮科很兴奋。
He told me that earlier that very same night, he'd been sifting through boxes that were being tossed out before the station's big move. And he'd found a bunch of racy notes written by the morning show's old, dour anchorman to a young camerawoman. Pico and I, we galloped out back to the dumpsters and mucked about until we found the stack of steamy pages.
他告诉我，就在同一天晚上早些时候，他一直在翻看在电视台大搬迁前被扔掉的盒子。他发现了一大堆晨间节目老而严厉的主播写给一名年轻摄像师的色情笔记。皮科和我，我们奔向后面的垃圾箱，挖来挖去直到我们找到了那一叠热腾腾的页面。
"You should read some of these on the show," Pico cried. I thought this could be a terrible idea. But Pico was vehement. "This guy's a class-A [BLEEP]," he said. "I'm telling you. He got a janitor fired for throwing out his lucky tie that he left on the bathroom floor. She had worked here eight years."
“你应该在节目上读一些这些，”皮科喊道。我以为这可能是一个糟糕的主意。但皮科很强烈。“这家伙是个一等[消音]，”他说。“我告诉你。他让一名清洁工因为扔掉了他留在浴室地板上的幸运领带而被解雇。她在那里工作了八年。”
Three hours later, we were on the air. And the anchorman was turning to me with a grumpy look. "So tell me about this book. You collect trash, is that it? You like trash, trashy trash? One person's treasures, another's treasure."
三小时后，我们正在播出。主播带着怀疑的眼神转向我。“那么告诉我关于这本书。你收集垃圾，是这样吗？你喜欢垃圾，垃圾中的垃圾？一个人的宝贝，另一个人的宝贝。”
He might very well have been drunk at 7:15 in the morning. "Yes, sir," I said. "People are finding this stuff all over the country, all over the world really, and sending it in to us. It's amazing how powerfully you can get a sense of someone just from a little ripped piece of paper you pick up off the grass-- like this one, for example. Seems like it's a guy who's trying to woo a girl by describing what he'd like to do with her breasts."
他很有可能在早上7点15分喝醉了。“是的，先生，”我说。“人们在全国各地发现这些东西，在全世界也是，并寄给我们。看到你仅仅从你从草地上捡起的一小片撕掉的纸，就能如此强烈地感受到某个人，这是令人惊叹的——就像这一张，例如。看起来这是一个试图通过描述他想对她的胸部做什么来追求一个女孩的家伙。”
I held his note up high and read it out loud. "Stacy, you've got a rack on you. Now that's a pair. I will [BLEEP] and [BLEEP] on them. Quit playing hard to get." What an expression that fellow had on his face. For a moment, his mouth, his nostrils, his eyes, and each eyebrow seemed to burst with separate looks of stunned confusion, outrage, remorse, and panic.
我把他的笔记高高举起，大声朗读。“斯泰西，你有一个货架。那真是一对。我将[消音]和[消音]在它们上。放弃假装很难追。”那个家伙脸上的表情。片刻之间，他的嘴、他的鼻孔、他的眼睛和每一根眉毛似乎都迸发出惊愕的困惑、愤怒、懊悔和恐慌的各种表情。
Then, in an instant, he recovered-- a true professional. And he asked me, "So did you bring any other kinds of notes?" I had to admit, Pico was right-- great idea. Back in the lobby, Pico stood with two janitors by a big TV set. And as I walked out into the bright, blurry morning sun, they applauded and whistled and called after me, "Good job, man. Good job."
然后，瞬间，他恢复了——一个真正的职业选手。他问我，“那么你带了任何其他种类的笔记吗？”我不得不承认，皮科是对的——伟大的主意。回到大厅，皮科和两名清洁工站在一台大电视机旁。当我走到明亮、模糊的清晨阳光下时，他们鼓掌、吹哨并向我喊，“做得好，老兄。做得好。”
Davy Rothbart, he's the creator of Found Magazine. And he writes essays and books. You can find his work at myheartisanidiotbook.com.
戴维·罗斯巴特，他是Found Magazine的创造者。他写散文和书。你可以在myheartisanidiotbook.com找到他的作品。
[MUSIC - "OPPORTUNITY" BY THE JEWELS]
[音乐 - "OPPORTUNITY" BY THE JEWELS]
Act Four, Function of the Heart. When you're a kid and you're frustrated with something in your life, your strategies are kind of limited for how you can fix what's wrong. When Elspeth was a kid, she saw an opening. She got an idea.
第四幕，心脏的功能。当你是个孩子，你对生活中的某件事感到沮丧时，你关于如何解决错误的事情的策略是有限的。埃尔斯佩斯是个孩子时，她看到了一个开口。她有了个主意。
And she got results. She definitely got results. Mainly, she wanted to get closer to her dad, who was a doctor. She says what she knew about him already was mostly, well, he worked in a hospital with a lot of old men.
她得到了结果。她绝对得到了结果。主要是，她想离她的医生爸爸更近一点。她说她关于他所知道的已经主要是，嗯，他在一家有很多老人的医院工作。
It was always a relationship where I was always just desperate for attention and for knowledge of him. I wanted to know what he was like, what he did, what he was interested in. And he was extremely un-forthcoming on every front.
那总是这种关系，我一直渴望关注和对他的了解。我想知道他是什么样的人，他做什么，他感兴趣什么。而他在所有方面都极其不直白。
So I would ask him things like, where are you going? And he would say, out. And I would say, out where? And he would say, just out. And it would turn into that kind of incredibly frustrating word game, which he would-- he would sort of treat it as though this was playful fun. And I just remember by the end of it, I was just enraged.
所以我总是问他类似，你要去哪儿？而他会说，出去。我会说，去哪儿？他会说，只是出去。那会变成那种极其令人沮丧的文字游戏，他会——他会某种程度上把它当作是好玩的。我只是记得到最后，我只是被激怒了。
Was he actually around? Like would he be home at night?
他真的在吗？比如他晚上会在家吗？
Yeah. He was home. But it was important to him to have quiet. So when he'd come home, he would want quiet. And of course we were-- we would scream with enthusiasm that he would be there. And he would be clearly kind of affronted with all the noise.
是的。他在家。但他拥有安静对他很重要。所以当他回家时，他会想要安静。当然我们是——我们会带着热情尖叫他会在那儿。他会很清楚地带着那种吵闹被冒犯。
So I was 11 sort of at the height of, I would say, desperation to get something from him. And this was a thing that was set up by the Unitarian Church. Parents would come in, and they would teach a little class in their specialty.
所以我11岁时某种程度上处于那个高度，我会说，从他那里得到某种东西的渴望。这是一件由一神论教堂设置的事情。父母会进来，他们会教一点关于他们专业的小课。
And so my dad had volunteered. Being a doctor, he was going to give a class on the function of the heart. It was going to be on the function of the heart. And so I, of course, decided I was going to sign up for my dad's course. Because I really wanted to finally figure out what he did.
所以我爸爸自愿参加了。作为医生，他要上一堂关于心脏功能的课。那将是关于心脏的功能。所以，当然，我决定我要报名参加我爸爸的课程。因为我真的想最终找出他做什么。
So one of my good friends, Ruthie, also signed up. So there were the two of us. And so he had gone out, and he had bought this at a butcher-- he'd gone to a butcher and brought this massive, raw, bloody cow heart in to demonstrate the function of the heart.
所以我的一个好朋友，鲁西，也报名了。所以是我们俩。他出去了，他在肉铺买了这个——他去了肉铺带了这个巨大的、生的、血淋淋的牛心来演示心脏的功能。
So the class begins and you see this bloody heart. And automatically, are you horrified to start because you thought it would be something else?
所以课开始了，你看到了这个血淋淋的心脏。而自动地，你因为认为那会是别的东西而感到恐惧吗？
Oh, no, no. I was quite riveted. No, very cool-looking, and actually genuinely interested in the topic as well. And so he had sliced open the heart, and he opened it up. And we went through the various functions of the heart. And then he would ask questions.
哦，不，不。我相当着迷。不，看起来很酷，而且实际上也真心对这个话题感兴趣。所以他切开了心脏，他把它打开了。我们经历了心脏的各种功能。然后他会问问题。
And there are two of us in the class. And even so, I raised my hand every time. And I don't just raise my hand. I raise my hand like, uh, uh, uh. "It's me. I know the answer. I have this. This is the question. This is the question." Yeah.
课里只有我们两个人。即便如此，我每次都举手。我不只是举手。我举手就像，呃，呃，呃。“是我。我知道答案。我得到了这个。这是问题。这是问题。”是的。
And then he would pause. And Ruth would be sitting there quite quietly, and then he would ask what my question would be. And then I would ask the question. And then he would explain and go into a long, long explanation. And he's a very quiet man. He's a very, very quiet person, not used to speaking.
然后他会停顿。鲁西会坐在那儿相当安静，然后他会问我的问题会是什么。然后我会问问题。然后他会解释并进入一个长长的、长长的解释。他是一个非常安静的人。他是一个非常、非常安静的人，不习惯说话。
So the explanations would go on for quite some time. And then he would ask another question. And I would again raise my hand-- and not just raise it, but pump it. I would pump my arm. And so the whole class was just me dominating the classroom over Ruthie, my very dear friend who was the soul of discretion throughout-- very subtle, kind of acute reading of the room dynamic, I would say, for an 11-year-old. Stayed right out of it.
所以解释会持续相当长的时间。然后他会问另一个问题。我会再次举手——而且不只是举起，而是抽动它。我会抽动我的手臂。所以整个课堂只是我统治了教室，盖过了鲁西，我那个非常亲爱的朋友，她在整个过程中体现了克制——非常微妙，我会说，对于一个11岁的人来说，对房间动态的一种敏锐解读。完全没介入。
And that was the class. And after that class, I felt great. I loved it. I felt like I'd had this great class with my dad.
而那便是课堂。在那之后，我觉得很棒。我爱它。我觉得我跟我爸爸上了这堂伟大的课。
That he saw your smart questions, and that he actually answered your questions, and gave you the attention.
他看到了你聪明的问题，而且他实际上回答了你的问题，给了你关注。
That's right. And that I finally had some evidence about what it was that he actually did. It was a great moment. And I felt afterwards like I'd really kind of finally connected with my dad.
没错。而且我最终得到了一些证据关于他实际上做了什么。这是一个伟大的时刻。我之后觉得好像我真的某种程度上最终跟我爸爸连接上了。
Just the poetry of it, of you in this classroom, this formal setting, with your dad-- and your best friend there for protection, basically-- and a bloody heart cut open, sitting there in between you.
仅仅是它的诗意，你在这个教室里，这个正式的场合，和你爸爸在一起——而且你最好的朋友在那里作为保护，基本上——还有一个切开的血淋淋的心脏，坐在你们之间。
No. It's quite the tableau, yeah. But then, a couple of days later, my mother took me aside. And she sort of raised the issue about how important it was to be a quiet person. You don't want to be the loud person. This was the message. You don't want to be the loud person. You want to be the quiet person.
不。那确实是一幅画面，是的。但后来，几天后，我母亲把我拉到一边。她某种程度上提出了关于做一个安静的人是多么重要的问题。你不想成为吵闹的人。这就是信息。你不想成为吵闹的人。你想做一个安静的人。
And by the time she's saying that, I know exactly what she's telling me. I had offended the sensibilities of my father, who would prefer that I was like Ruthie, the quiet person in the classroom. So here I thought that I was doing the right thing. And then what I learned, after the fact, was that I had been loud and vulgar somehow and that I should have just shut up and been the quiet person.
当她说这话的时候，我知道她完全是在告诉我什么。我冒犯了我父亲的感受，他更希望我像鲁西一样，那个教室里安静的人。所以在这里我以为我正在做正确的事情。然后我学到的，事后看来，是我曾经吵闹和庸俗，某种程度上，我应该只是闭嘴做个安静的人。
So you must've been completely mortified.
所以你一定感到完全羞愧。
I felt like a fool, I think, afterwards in some sense, that I had been so deluded, that I had gotten it so profoundly wrong.
我觉得我像个傻瓜，我想，事后在某种意义上，我曾经如此受骗，我把它彻底弄错了。
And so was it helpful that your mom gave you this information? Or was it not so helpful in retrospect?
所以你妈妈给你这个信息有帮助吗？还是回顾起来没那么有帮助？
It was helpful, but not in the sense that it was intended to be helpful. What my mother was telling me was to become quiet. And I just never did. And so that advice was not helpful. But knowing that I should be quiet was helpful.
有帮助，但不是在那旨在有帮助的意义上。我母亲告诉我的是变得安静。但我从来没做过。所以那条建议没帮助。但知道我应该安静是有帮助的。
Because I knew that my dad was wrong. And I knew-- I knew-- that my behavior was completely acceptable and, in fact, was a good thing. And that was a moment when I realized, I have to kind of strategize around this relationship in a way that a child shouldn't have to. I've got to be more crafty about this in order to get through this childhood thing.
因为我知道我爸爸是错的。而且我知道——我知道——我的行为是完全可以接受的，而且，事实上，是一件好事。那是一个时刻，我意识到，我必须某种程度上绕过这段关系制定策略，以一种孩子不应该有的方式。我必须在这方面更狡猾一点，为了熬过这个童年的事情。
I mean it's funny because the thing you're describing is this moment of a kid understanding that their parents really don't have it together all the time and are doing the wrong thing. And everybody has gone through that moment with their parents at some point. And in a way, that's an amazing thing to have happen at 11.
我是说这很有趣因为你描述的事情是那种孩子理解他们的父母并不是总是能掌握住，并且在做错事的时刻。每个人在某一点上都经历过那个时刻与他们的父母。在某种程度上，这是一个11岁时发生的惊人的事情。
Yeah. And I did finally get to the point where I accepted the fact that I'm never going to be the quiet person. I'm always going to be an enthusiastic person who, if I have a great question, I will pump my arm. And I will continue to offend him for the duration.
是的。我最终确实到了一个地步，我接受了这样一个事实，我永远不会成为安静的人。我总会是一个热情的、如果我有一个伟大的问题，我会抽动我的手臂的人。而且我会为了持续的时间继续冒犯他。
And then, of course, I took up the trumpet, which is the world's loudest, most vulgar instrument-- at 11, now that I think of it. So very shortly after this, I took up the trumpet. I thought, what is the loudest possible instrument I could choose? So yeah, no, I went right for the trumpet.
然后，当然，我拿起了小号，这是世界上最吵、最庸俗的乐器——在11岁时，现在我想起来。所以在那之后不久，我拿起了小号。我想，我能选择的最吵的乐器是什么？所以是的，不，我直接奔向了小号。
Elspeth Carruthers, she's executive director for the Neubauer Collegium for Society and Culture at the University of Chicago. Since we first broadcast this story, Elspeth's dad has died. He was 83.
埃尔斯佩斯·卡鲁瑟斯，她是芝加哥大学诺伊鲍尔社会与文化学院的执行主任。自从我们第一次广播这个故事以来，埃尔斯佩斯的爸爸已经去世了。他83岁。
Our program was produced today by Amy O'Leary and myself, with Alex Blumberg, Diane Cook, Jane Feltes, Sarah Koenig, Chris Swetala, and Lisa Pollak. Our senior producer for today's show is Julie Snyder. Production help from Alvin Melathe and Matt Tierney. Music help from Jessica Hopper.
我们的节目今天由艾米·奥利里和我制作，亚历克斯·布卢姆伯格、黛安·库克、简·费尔特斯、莎拉·柯尼希、克里斯·斯韦塔拉和丽莎·波拉克。我们今天节目的高级制片人是朱莉·斯奈德。制作帮助来自阿尔文·梅拉斯和马特·蒂尔尼。音乐帮助来自杰西卡·霍珀。
Paul Bacon, the policeman who I talked to at the beginning of the program, is no longer a policeman. He's written a book about his experience as a cop. It's called Bad Cop, New York's Least Likely Police Officer Tells All. Information at paulbacon.com.
保罗·培根，我在节目开始时采访的警察，不再是警察了。他写了一本关于他作为警察经历的书。它叫《坏警察，纽约最不可能的警官讲述一切》。信息在paulbacon.com。
[ACKNOWLEDGEMENTS]
[鸣谢]
Our website, thisamericanlife.org. This American Life is distributed by PRX, the Public Radio Exchange. Special thanks, as always, to our program's co-founder, Mr. Torey Malatia, who swears that thing he said to me about the way I look in the new shirt I bought-- he swears it's all a misunderstanding.
我们的网站，thisamericanlife.org。《美国生活》由PRX，公共广播交易所分发。特别感谢，像往常一样，我们节目的共同创始人，托里·马拉蒂亚先生，他发誓关于我买的新衬衫我看起来的样子他对我说的那些话——他发誓那全是误解。
"I didn't mean to say that [BLEEP]. It just came out, I swear to God."
“我不是故意要说那个[消音]的。它只是出来了，我向上帝发誓。”
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周回来带给你更多《美国生活》的故事。